in mid-january a hospital in everett
washington announced a patient had
tested positive for a deadly new strain
of coronavirus
the cause of the yet to be named disease
covid19
it was the first reported case in the
united states
concerning but still a relatively small
threat compared to the growing outbreak
in china but fast forward six months and
the united states has the most recorded
coronavirus cases in the world
so how did it spread in the united
states
looking back public health experts have
pointed to a series of missteps and
miscalculations in the u.s response
a response that has been polarizing and
painful
and launched the country into a deadly
game of catch-up with a pandemic that
has yet to subside
[Music]
the first major action the united states
takes against coronavirus
is to restrict travelers coming from
china the first case in everett
washington
and a second case in chicago both were
from travelers who had recently returned
from the chinese province at the heart
of the outbreak
but the virus was also circulating in
europe around this time
a second front of infiltration that will
go overlooked
for several weeks in early february
u.s efforts center on how to safely
screen and repatriate americans
returning from asia like those
quarantined on the diamond princess
cruise liner in japan
this outbreak is the largest outside of
mainland china
and shows how rapidly the virus can
spread if left
unchecked public health experts say that
a widespread deployment of testing in
the u.s
is essential for containment but test
kits sent by the cdc to public health
labs across the country proved to be
faulty
and the labs are told they shouldn't use
them the fda bars independent labs from
using tests they've developed themselves
and health officials say the public
should not wear masks as the virus
silently spreads across the country
experts warn of a testing bottleneck
that can't keep up with demand
despite the president's reassurances
anybody that wants a test can get a test
that's what i as the cdc expands the
criteria for who can be tested
infection hot spots appear across the
country
one emerges in new rochelle new york the
national guard is deployed to establish
a one square mile quarantine zone within
the new york city suburb
but by that point patients and their
family members had already traveled to
several locations throughout the metro
area
including a synagogue and a school
the nation's top infectious disease
expert tells congress the country's
testing strategy
isn't working the system does not
is not really geared to what we need
right now
what you are asking for that is a
failing
in mid-march the coronavirus outbreak is
declared a national emergency
as the country comes to grips with the
fact that the lack of testing has made
containment more difficult
shortly after six bay area counties
enact the first stay-at-home orders in
the country
closing all non-essential businesses the
entire state of california soon follows
preceding a cascade of 42 state closures
over the next
three weeks after initially saying
people shouldn't wear masks
the cdc reverses course in early april
recommending they be worn in public
guidance that is highly politicized as
americans become split on the severity
of the outbreak
the perils of the virus are on full
display at the outbreak's epicenter in
new york city
icus are overwhelmed as officials try to
rapidly increase hospital capacity to
treat patients
and confront the mounting number of
deaths i'm tired of walking into rooms
and
your patients are dead uh
you just walk into a room there's a dead
body there
tired calling families until you're bad
news
in less hard-hit areas americans protest
stay-at-home orders
often without masks to compel governors
to reopen their economies
by the end of may economic pressures
have driven every state to ease
lockdowns
despite health experts saying only three
states meet reopening guidelines set by
the trump administration
these guidelines call for extensive
testing and contact tracing
but states have a tough time
implementing these measures
for a few reasons first testing still
isn't widely available
one analysis in late may concludes that
53 of us counties don't have a testing
site
and this lack of testing
disproportionately impacts
minority communities second reopening
states don't have the resources to trace
infections
a recent analysis finds that florida's
department of health
needs 33 000 contact tracers the state
currently has just over 2 300.
officials warn that bars restaurants and
summer gatherings
are ground zero for infections as
asymptomatic young people drive a surge
in new cases protesters demonstrate
against police violence and
institutionalized racism
as the virus continues to
disproportionately affect minority
communities
and by the end of june the epicenter of
the outbreak shifts to the south and
west
as cases spike in florida texas arizona
and california
and forces some states to roll back or
slow down reopenings
we are now having 40 plus thousand new
cases
a day i would not be surprised if we go
up
to a hundred thousand a day if this does
not turn around
and so i am very concerned by mid-july
13 states see new infections rise by
over 20 percent compared to the previous
week
and florida sets a new single day record
of over 15 000 new cases
as the country debates whether schools
should reopen in the fall
the coronavirus outbreak in the united
states has proven difficult to manage
and so it's difficult to predict what
will happen next
but public health experts say learning
from the costly mistakes of the past six
months
may be crucial in plotting a path
[Music]
forward